Mày mì hai thằng tám, giờ lãnh đạo liên mình cho ông A-U, nhưng mạnh,
của bây nâh phải có quyền tự quét về tưởng là của mình.
Đặc biệt trong bối cảnh của gặp giữa tổng thủ Mỹ đường năng trám,
và tổng thủng áp lãnh nghiệp của tiên sắp dịch ra tại Alaska.
Căn nước A-U khẳng địch có đường hoặc biệt không thể quy địch,
nhiều thiếu sự tham gia của kia và mọi thật phải tốn trọng là của tiếp.
Mà gồm nốc lập và tọn bệnh lãnh thổ, cho bối cảnh nâh.
Mà gồm lãnh thổ trong bài pháp biểu gần đây,
là mấy người lòng ngày mẹ sẽ phải từ bỏ những uống gặp đăng lý ngà kìm sóa.
Mà kiểu của anh, trong thống dưới lệ sĩ hoàn ngàn tương bố của A-U và kêu bỏ đoàn kết,
lệng ngà không thể lửa rồi, có đồ của tiếp.
Tuy nhiên, trong mọi bộ A-U cũng tổn tại bất đồng.
Thủ tưởng không gà rì bích còo bàn là chỉ trách đường bố uống của người quay nâh.
Và cho rằng thay thì có lập A-U nên tổ chức hội nghĩ thông định với nha để lắng nghe lúc cầu của mắt cơ và
có thể thay thức định ngà mấy đàn làm dưới lên lòng ngày dòng,
chính quyền của ông đường năng trăm có thể đăng tư tiền lợi ích dân mà bỏ qua anh đến của châu Âu
cũng như bức trạng điện chính chi dọc lẫn.
Cúc liên quan tài của xung đồn. Ngay trước thêm của gặp của hai ông trăm và buộc tin
có đổi nha đã có bức tiền đảng kể ở mình đấu của quay nâh.
Cú thể là xuyên thùng phòng tuyên ở đồ nhét.
Đây rồi, tôi không cần quan trăm của quay nâh.
Nhong phần tích đi vstach, cho biết nếu là sự thật nơi sẽ là một trong những bức tiền lợi nhất của ngà cho
nằm qua khi họ tìm cách kiểu sốt quan tỏng của vực và sật biệt cho đợi tình công tiêu theo.
Bố tổng thăm như quay nâh cho biết là glượng ngà đàn lợi giúp yêu thay quan số.
Lên thục tần công với tổng thất lợi nhưng bận gây áp lực mắt lên phòng để quay nâh.